and from what I can tell it's a result
of Saddam beating the hell out of his
kids and just being a horrible vacant
father yeah like I had a vision of of
him being like the his one regret in
life Saddam Hussein is that he didn't
spend time with his kids that he didn't
love his kids I feel like that's
probably that's so sweet it was like his
soul I was like that's the cutest thing
I've ever heard I pictured him like just
wishing that he could spend time with
the sunset and his children
after all was said and done
you are adorable I want to hug you
it's God's energy I think people are
giving Ian 20s for this one
or is that the Nicola thing I don't know
they are one of the most like empathetic
and compassionate people like yeah even
even when you're referring some of the
most evil people you have the most what
was it I'm the most uh modest I'm the
most modest of all yeah
radical empathy have mixed feelings on
taking out dictators